it's time for drew's news your friendly
news gardeners planting those good new
seeds and with me at the desk best
co-pilot on the planet and i do mean
that rossi ross
matthews today i'm really excited
because we have an epic desk guest she
is a writer an actress and entrepreneur
and you can catch her on the seventh and
final season of grace and
oh frankie god it's good to be here
it feels right feels really right
i mean
you and your uh often collaborator casey
wilson were kind enough to come on the
show when
nobody knew what it was we were in the
height of a pandemic and thank you for
taking that leap with us back in the day
are you kidding me
what and then fun fact your husband paul
is the first person who brought the
drew's news zoom to life oh yeah the
background followed his model ever since
but he's the origin story that's her
husband paul shearer i mean are we
should i be expecting like some
commission on this show or
residual check in the mail yeah you do
you should speaking of cuts
that dress you are looking so beautiful
and you work alongside of two legends
lily tomlin and jane fonda this is the
final season
of grace and frankie
the show has lasted seven seasons
[Applause]
love it so crazy
[Music]
i
and listen so so it's interesting to
kind of talk about it now because it's
coming out the final season premieres
april 29th but we finished in november
any fun
fly on the wall surprises about the
icons of jane and lily that come off the
top of your head i mean i think they
were very nervous to work with me yeah
right yeah you know what i mean just to
be
in the presence of a legend
so i just tried to tell them like i'm
just a regular gal
you know like there's nothing to be
worried about so sweet of you i think
i think the thing i love the most about
them is how often both jane and lily
use siri
whoa really yeah i love that yeah that's
so funny it's just
i mean i'm using siri very occasionally
with you know very judiciously
but they are fully transcribing texts to
people and full emails new paragraphs
they're fully
living their lives on siri oh this is
the best tip ever i love it i love this
intel it's so interesting i feel like
siri doesn't like me but if it's good
enough for jade and lily it is good
enough for everyone but me
[Music]
you